هناك عروض سيارات ،
ثم هناك معرض جنيف
للسيارات هنا ، يمكنك مشاهدة فولكس فاجن
نيسان وفورد ، كما يمكنك مشاهدة
بوجاتيس فيراريس ولامبورجيني
وشركات سيارات غريبة ربما لم
تسمع عنها من قبل مثل زين القوس والحافة
بينما عروض السيارات الأخرى تكافح من أجل
اكتشف طرقًا للبقاء مثيرًا ،
لا يبدو أن عرض جنيف يعاني من مشكلة
المفضلة لدي ، حيث سيكون مكان البدء
هنا في جناح أستون مارتن في عام 1976
، كانت لاجوندا هي أول سيارة مزودة
بمحرك يتم التحكم فيه عن طريق الكمبيوتر ، والآن عادت
إلى كل شيء-  السيارة ذات المفهوم الكهربائي
[موسيقى]
بعد إعادة إحياء سيارة كلاسيكية حديثة
Toyota gr Supra هي نظرة مفهوم سيارة السباق
تحت الأجنحة والطلاء اللامع
لرؤية سوبرا الجديدة يتم تطويرها بواسطة
Toyota و BMW أخيرًا بينما كان الجميع
يتحدثون عن  Jaguar تتطلع إلى
سيارات الدفع الرباعي الكهربائية السريعة ،
يمكن أن تصنع Hyundai Kona electric دفقة أكبر من Jaguars
و Tesla's رائعة ولكن من
المحتمل أن ترى الكثير منها
على الطريق